for a long time it hasn't been clear
what could possibly prompt a tech
oligarch in this country to apologize
for anything really everybody knows that
Tim Cook will never say he's sorry about
working with sweat shops in China just
like Jeff Bezos will never apologize for
apologize for selling all of the garbage
products that these sweat shops produce
and you certainly won't hear Mark
Zuckerberg say that he regrets his
efforts to manipulate the last
presidential election spent hundreds of
millions of dollars to influence
everything from mail and voting to the
design of the physical B
that were delivered to voters homes and
to this day he he seems to be proud of
it he also doesn't seem that bothered by
Facebook's decision to censor the hunter
Biden laptop story he certainly didn't
release the Facebook version of the
Twitter files or anything like that
there was no meaningful mayaula
Zuckerberg just said that the situation
quote sucks and that was the end of it
that's what makes this moment from
yesterday's Hearing in the Senate
Judiciary Committee on online child
safety so interesting after some
prodding from Senator Josh Hol of
Missouri Zuckerberg stood up and
apologized to the families seated behind
him and these are families who say that
their children were exploited or died
because they encountered content on
meta's social media apps whether that's
because they were bullied and committed
suicide or because they bought drugs on
Instagram or they participated in the
Blackout Challenge and suffocated uh or
they were in child pornography um or
other unspeakable Horrors along those
lines and they were were all there and
and uh after being again prompted to do
so Mark Zuckerberg stood up and this is
what he said who did you fire yeah I
said you mischaracterized 37% of teenage
girls between 13 and 15 were exposed to
unwanted nudity in a week on Instagram
you knew about it who did you fire
Senator this is why we're building all
did tools Senator that's I don't think
that that's who did you fire I'm not
going to answer that um you didn't fire
anybody right you didn't take any sign
it's appropriate to talk about like IND
decisions do you know who's sitting
behind you you've got families from
across the nation whose children are
either severely harmed or gone and you
don't think it's appropriate to take a
talk about steps that you took the fact
that you didn't fire a single person let
me ask you this let me ask you this have
you compensated any of the victims sorry
have you compensated any of the victims
these girls have you compensated them I
don't believe so you why
not don't you think they deserve some
compensation for what your platform has
done help with counseling services help
with dealing with the issues that your
your servic has caused our our job is to
make sure that we build tools to help
keep people safe are you going to
compensate them Senator our job and what
we take seriously is making sure that we
build industry-leading tools to find
harmful cont take it off the services to
make money and to build tools that
Empower parents any action you didn't
take any action you didn't fire anybody
you haven't compensated a single victim
let me ask you this let me ask you this
there's families of victims here today
have you apologize to the victims I
would you like to do so now well they're
here you're on National Television would
you like now to apologize to the victims
who have been harmed by your prodct show
them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good people
I I I I'm sorry for everything that you
have all gone through it's terrible no
one should have to go through the things
that your families have have
suffered so it's hard to hear exactly
what Zuckerberg says there so here's the
quote I'm sorry for everything you've
all gone through nobody should have to
go through what your families have
suffered this is why we have invested so
much and are going to continue industry
leading efforts to make sure that no one
has to go through the types of things
your families have suffered um now this
is being treated as sort of an
unscripted moment uh I you know maybe it
was but it's still worth dissecting one
way or another a little bit the
implication of what Mark Zuckerberg said
is that if his social media platforms
had done more maybe these people's
children would still be alive as
carefully workshopped as this apology is
it's still an unprecedented Mission from
the head of a major technology company
even though Zuckerberg stopped short of
admitting that his products were
directly responsible for any deaths he
did convey some some at least some sense
of remorse to these grieving families
and that's the headline that's been
blasted everywhere in the media as you
might expect but it's important to
clarify exactly what meta is accused of
and what Mark Zuckerberg is apologizing
for Last Summer the Wall Street Journal
reported that Instagram not only hosts
child pornography but also promotes
child pornography through its algorithm
this was a discovery that incidentally
did not prompt any kind of sustained
Advertiser boycott from major
corporations unlike the time Elon Musk
agreed with a post that criticized the
ADL but any event Instagram was exposed
to promoting some of the worst kind of
content imaginable
as Ted Cruz demonstrated at yesterday's
hearing Instagram didn't even block
child pornography that its algorithm had
identified and here's how Mark
Zuckerberg explained that Instagram also
displayed the following warning
screen to individuals who were searching
for child abuse
material the these results may contain
images of child sexual abuse and then
you gave users two choices
get
resources or see results
anyway Mr Zuckerberg what the hell were
you
thinking all right Senator um the the
the basic science behind that is that
when people are searching for something
that is problematic it's often helpful
to rather than just blocking it to help
direct them towards something that um
that could be helpful for getting them
to get help in what I understand get
resources in what San universe is there
a link for C results anyway well because
we might be wrong we we try to trigger
this this uh warning or we tried to
um when we think that there's any chance
that the result okay you might be wrong
let me ask you how many times was this
Waring screen displayed I don't know but
the but the you don't know why don't you
know I I I don't know the answer to that
off the top of my head well that's a bad
enough excuse on its own sure it's
conceivable that content that isn't
child pornography may have gotten caught
up in the algorithmic net as uh
Zuckerberg is suggesting but you don't
you don't show the content anyway out of
fear of censoring non-child pornography
if you think it might be child
pornography you just shut it down period
obviously that's what you should do but
the problem for Instagram is that even
beyond that for years they refuseed to
censor even child pornography that was
right out in the open according to the
journal users on Instagram could use
hashtags like pre-teen text to find
these materials and the platform made no
effort to shut that down it was like a
Twitter before Elon Musk bought it when
Yol Roth was running things and at most
users would get this little dialogue box
which they could easily dismiss even
when there was no doubt what they were
looking for to the extent that
Zuckerberg was apologizing for anything
yesterday's hearing it was it was this
flagrant disregard for the welfare of
children and possibly for the various
federal laws against child pornography
that his company may or may not have
violated um and that apology is long
overdue I mean that's the least he could
have offered under these circumstances
and it's not even close to enough but to
be clear Zuckerberg was not apologizing
for the mental health effects of
Instagram and Facebook you may have
heard that he was but it's not really
true and we can be sure of that because
later on in the heing Zuckerberg denied
that there's any research showing that
his products impair the mental well
well-being of young people
watch mental health is a complex issue
and the existing body of scientific work
has not shown a cause a link between
using social media and young people
having worse mental health
outcomes this is the part of Mark
Zuckerberg's testimony that underscores
why no one and uh in in particular no
parent should ever rely on big Tech oler
Gars or US senators for that matter to
safeguard their children on the internet
first of all you know you don't need to
look at existing research to know that
excessive social media use is bad for
children it's just common sense you can
tell intuitively that children who spend
staring at a screen are going to suffer
as a result our brains are not wired to
scroll endlessly through social media
feeds and typically when you do things
that are extremely unnatural especially
when you're a child whose brain is
constantly changing and it's unnatural
again to just sit there staring at a
screen for hours a day we're not made to
do that as human beings and but if you
do that then then bad things happen as a
result we don't need research to tell us
that because we all know it's true
there's something magical about reliving
old family films as I sit down and Press
Play I'm transported back in time the
flickering image on the screen are more
than just recordings they are reminders
of how I came to be the man that I am
today thanks to Legacy box I can access
those precious memories at the touch of
a button you can relive your memories to
Simply create your own legacy box filled
with camcorder tapes film reels and
pictures you get digital copies that can
be easily enjoyed shared and organized
it's like magic Legacy box is the
world's largest digitizer they've helped
over 1 million families relive their
wedding days chaotic childhood sporting
events and even those long road trips
and by going to legacybox.com mat you
can enjoy 50% off as well but you have
to hurry this offer won't last long
start preserving your past and save 50%
go to legacybox.com mat to get started
today that's legacybox.com
slmt and putting aside the actual
content that kids are engaging with on
the internet ignoring the fact that much
of the content is actively harmful and
degrading and bad and toxic um and
worse just the very fact that children
are spending the majority of their
waking hours staring at a little glowing
rectangle is troubling enough on its own
you know if you went up to someone who
didn't know anything about the internet
maybe someone who just came here through
a time portal from 1920 and you told
them that the focal point of life for
most children in our culture is a little
screen and they spend almost all their
time just staring at this thing and they
care about nothing as much as they care
about the screen that person would
automatically recognize that this is a
very bad development no other
information is required in fact he would
go back in his in the time machine to
his own time period in a panic Having
learned that human beings 100 years in
the future have become voluntarily
zombified no research required to know
that it is bad but in any event we do
have research and there's a lot of it
researchers have demonstrated a causal
link between social media use and poor
mental health outcomes it's not just
correlation it goes beyond that Jonathan
height is one of the leading uh social
Psych ologist in the country he's at NYU
and here's how he responded yesterday
quote Zuckerberg is wrong there are now
dozens of experiments showing causality
I laid out the evidence and here's some
of the evidence as psychology Professor
uh Jean twang has noted quote teen
pregnancy crime physical fights and
child poverty are all down since 2010
but teen depression doubled it should
have gone down but it didn't because
smartphones and social media led to
social isolation and sleep deprivation
it was in the year 2012 the first year
that a majority of children in this
country possessed a smartphone that Teen
Mental Health plummeted and you can see
I mean it's very clear in the chart it's
like smartphones are introduced and then
alongsid it depression everything else
Skyrocket twang looked at more than a
dozen other possible explanations from
Co to the economy and none of them fully
explained what was happening and you
could just look at the charts and see
how Stark the change is the chart shows
that the percent of us adolescence and
adults with major depression in the last
year 2005 to 2021 it's from the national
survey of drug use and health as you
expect the graphs for the Youth suicide
rate look similar and as far as these
researchers can tell there's no other
serious alternative explanation for
what's happening here except cell phone
and social media use that's because this
phenomenon happens all over the world
across varying economic conditions
everywhere that kids had cell phones
mental health
declined and pretty much at the exact
rate that they were getting cell phones
the same pattern played out in five
Nordic Nations Sweden Denmark Norway
Iceland and Finland of course this
doesn't mean that there that that other
factors are not contributing in some way
to the decline in mental health in this
country the number of Americans who go
to church every week has dropped from 70
million in 2008 to 62 million in 2022
and still following falling for example
and that's not helping and obviously
it's not just uh happening because the
iPhone was invented there's also the
rise of victim culture in schools which
teach young people that nothing is ever
their fault they're always oppressed
they're always a victim you know they've
been trained to see themselves that way
as Gene twang writes in her book
monitoring the future many more young
people have an external Locust of
control quote unquote as compared to the
1970s and that means that they believe
that they don't have control over their
lives which is a feeling that leads to
higher instances of depression and
anxiety and this is what people are
trained to believe these days so this
has been a trend for some time but again
in the chart you see a massive Spike
around 2012 when most young people got
smartphones for the first
time and as far as arguments about
correlation go this one is pretty strong
but it gets stronger when you look at
the evidence showing causation and that
evidence is also mounting a study in
Jamma Pediatrics for example found that
regular social media use appears to
change the brains of young people it
modifies how they respond to social cues
quoting from the study quote this cohort
study examined whether early adolescent
frequency of checking behaviors on three
popular social media platforms Facebook
Instagram Snapchat was associated with
trajectories of functional brain
Development Across adolescence
adolescence who engaged in high habitual
checking behaviors that is checking
social media show distinct neural
trajectories when anticipating social
feedback compared with those who engaged
in moderate or low non-habitual checking
behaviors suggesting that habitual
social media checking early in
adolescence is associated with Divergent
brain development over time the study
goes on to state that researchers don't
yet know exactly what the effects of
this Divergent brain development might
be largely because this research is
still relatively new I mean all this
stuff is new but it does appear based on
all the evidence we have that social
media use is basically rewiring the
brains of young people it causes
development that is clearly unnatural
and not fully understood so again Common
Sense historical Trends medical research
are all pointing in the same direction
they're all pointing to the conclusion
that introducing kids to smartphones and
social media uh use especially early on
in childhood could cause or probably is
causing real and permanent damage now
given that
conclusion and the solution is sort of
obvious badgering Mark Zuckerberg at a
hearing is not going to solve the
problem and I'm all for having laws
protecting kids particularly when child
sex trafficking and pornography are
involved uh we need all the laws uh
possible to protect them there but at a
certain point in addition to that
parents need to be willing to do some
actual parenting accountability needs to
begin not with one Tech CEO or even all
of them but with the millions of parents
who give their kids devices with
internet access in the first place
according to the New York Presbyterian
Healthcare System 42% of kids have
smartphones by the age of 10
42% and 91% have a SmartPhone by 14 so
that means that almost all kids have
smartphones with internet access at
least two years before Society has
deemed them responsible enough to
operate a
vehicle there's just no conceivable
valid reason why a 10-year-old needs a
smartphone especially when dumb phones
that only call or text still exist and
can be purchased easily and are
cheaper the underlying problem is that
most of the parents are addicted to
social media too so they get their kids
started on the Habit so that frees up
more time for them to scroll their own
phones and that's how the phones have
taken over most households they become
the focal points of most
families that's the root of the problem
but of course Senators can't subpoena
millions of parents and yell at them and
that's not going to make a very good
television anyway so instead we demand
performative apologies from Tech
billionaires for making the dangerous
thing that we ourselves are willingly
buying and handing to our
children you know it's it's a lot like
handing your kid a cigarette
while simultaneously ranting about the
evils of the tobacco industry in this
case it's it's tempting to offload all
the blame to Mark Zuckerberg as
unlikable as he may be to many people
that's probably why there's so much uh
there was so much Applause at the
hearing yesterday as Zuckerberg was
dressed down by Josh Holly but there's
now clear evidence that children are
suffering while this theater plays out
in the Senate they're becoming more
depressed more addicted to drugs less
self- assured more xiety everything else
and so ring on smartphones that their
brains are are changing because of
it the solution is not to bully Mark
Zuckerberg even though he's maybe the
easiest person on the planet to bully
and I'm sure it is kind of
fun the real solution is something far
simpler but apparently quite radical
these days the solution is for parents
to be
parents hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code wall
should get two months free on all annual
plans see you there